this week on sound field since the
beginning of time a series of numbers
has inspired the world around us this
number can be seen almost anywhere you
look it's called the golden ratio and
you might have seen it but did you know
that you can also hear it have you ever
noticed how some pieces of music just
seem to make sense
the notes the chords phrases the
dynamics and harmony they can all feel
like they were meant to go together well
many people believe that this isn't
simply a coincidence but part of a
natural order to the universe something
called the golden ratio to explain the
golden ratio we asked our friend Joe
from it's okay to be smart to fill us in
the golden ratio is the irrational
number of Phi and like pi it doesn't end
so instead of saying one point six one
eight zero three three nine eight eight
seven and so on we'll just say five so
what's interesting about fine take this
golden rectangle it's golden because the
ratio between its sides match Phi if you
cut a square off a golden rectangle you
create a smaller rectangle for the same
golden proportions because this long
irrational number made sense visually
but couldn't be explained as a fraction
some ancient philosophers figured it
must have a higher meaning they called
it the golden ratio and later the divine
proportion
which brings us to something called the
Fibonacci sequence this pattern starts
with zero then each following number is
the sum the two before it and what does
that have to do with the golden ratio
was the sequence goes higher the ratio
between the numbers gets closer and
closer to one point six one eight or
five many believe this sequence could
explain growth in nature if you connect
each corner of the squares with a park
you get a golden spiral look familiar
a lot of people see these golden spirals
everywhere
I didn't know anything about gonna race
you I'm just worried even trying to
learn like okay in school I learned it
as okay a piece of music has a golden
section which is that that point that
climactic it doesn't always have to be
dramatic but just something special
always happens
music theories have claimed to find the
golden ratio in the works of many famous
classical composers from Mozart to WC
some say the golden ratio and the
Fibonacci sequence are evident in music
for Strings percussion and cluster the
Hungarian composer Bela Bartok for
example the opening xylophone solo in
the third movement has a rhythmic
pattern following the Fibonacci sequence
going from 1 2 3 5 8 and then back down
5 3 2 1
so Bartok I think was being accused of
being really cerebral in his music so he
was pretty notoriously silent about his
work you don't see like notes in the
margin with these little details right
so a lot of people have said well look
if he was doing this he was using
Fibonacci in the golden ratio you know
why didn't he tell people or why wasn't
it more obvious couldn't it just be that
certain pieces that have that line up
with the golden ratio stand out and then
music there is gravitate towards that as
an example yes absolutely
for example the chill esta that comes in
at like bar 77 in the first movement and
that has nothing to do with golden ratio
or Fibonacci ah but the piece in the
title is cellist oh right so that's
really important right does that mean
you know we just count all the other
stuff I mean I think you're right you
have to look at the beginning but then
in your opinion why should people care
about the golden ratio well so what we
haven't talked about is how it shows up
in a teacher so for example if you go
out and look at flowers and you start
counting flower petals most of the time
you'll find a Fibonacci number think
about like if you were gonna grow and
plant lots of seeds on a flower you
wouldn't just want to like equally
spread them out as you got further away
from the center there'd be too much
space nature doesn't want that right
nature wants the sunflower to procreate
so you have more seeds the better and it
turns out the optimal angle of where
they're arranging themselves is related
to the golden ratio
so put that all together and you've got
kind of a nice beautiful like mother
nature what could be more beautiful than
you know mountains and flowers and
streams right perhaps that's why
musicians have gravitated towards it in
terms of your writing a piece of music
and you have a climax in your piece now
where you gonna put it you're gonna put
it right in the middle no you're no
you're gonna put it a little off-center
so maybe it's time to gravitate toward
something like a golden ratio the climax
of Bartok first movement happens at bar
fifty five which is not only a Fibonacci
number but also lands very close to the
golden ratio
music theorists call this a five moment
Bartok isn't the only composer to have a
five moment finding one is simple take
the length of a song and then multiply
it by 0.618 the inverse of five for
example take under pressure by Queen and
David Bowie we have a total of two
hundred forty six seconds times 0.618
which equals one hundred and fifty-two
seconds now listen to what happens at
that exact
[Music]
if you look hard enough you'll start
finding it everywhere check out Drake's
in my feelings but we're all these
musicians writing songs with calculators
by the side I doubt it some say we find
these golden moments because humans are
just hardwired to find order in the
world but sometimes the order of the
Fibonacci sequence can be mesmerizing
like in this conical rhythm by BC
Montana Montana wrote this as a tribute
piece after the death of his father who
had introduced the Fibonacci sequence to
him as a teenager this style of music is
Carnatic music from southern India and
is characterized by a very complex
rhythmic system Monda not used the first
eight numbers at the Fibonacci sequence
to compose the intricate rhythms in this
piece by the way this is the five moment
of this video
I did write a piece using certain
elements of the golden proportions and
the Fibonacci numbers should I play it
for you it's really fresh but okay oh
you don't play alive oh let's get it I
don't hear this yes so what I did was I
just came up with a little motive and
then I fleshed it out until I felt like
it could go somewhere it's something can
change then I knew okay this is the
golden section and depending on the
rules of the golden proportions I know
exactly how much time is required until
the end
[Music]
so obviously here it changes right so I
try to make it as obvious as possible
but that is at the point where two
hundred sixteenth notes have passed and
the whole piece has three hundred twenty
four sixteenth notes okay so that point
at two hundred is golden section or the
five moment okay and this pattern I use
the Fibonacci numbers so this has five
sixteenth notes and then it goes to
eight sixteenth notes and then it goes
to thirteen sixteenth notes and then it
goes back down I don't know so what was
hard was it has to end by what three
hundred twenty four sixteenth notes
right so it's like how are we gonna end
this so I just bring back the petal
[Music]
I just kind of tried to evaporate it but
if that was difficult about this because
I was working with the structure alright
but using this type of format this type
of structure is another way of adding a
limitation to to what you're doing some
sort of some sort of puzzle to work
around so I found it really stimulating
people to think of limitations and
boundaries as negative words however
when you are creative you have so many
ideas coming to you you kind of need
those walls to create within exactly
it's so true just the template aspect of
it is very very valuable as a composer
since you've heard it can you help me
turn it into a piece with perhaps some
percussion or some drum sounds yes maybe
something with clapping yeah I got I got
some sounds I got some stuff for that
okay I wanna I'm excited answer that
first section though if you can't dance
to do dance and I was doing a build-up I
was doing that too
I
[Music]
[Music]
where do you notice the golden ratio
what do you think about mathematical
composition comment below and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]
you